>> Tucker: STEVE SCALISE SAID
THAT.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A -- SOUTH LOS ANGELES
HAS BEEN EVACUATED TONIGHT.
WORKERS DISCOVERED A SUSPICIOUS
PACKAGE ADDRESSED TO CONGRESSMAN
MAXINE WATERS.
CASEY BC FOX LOS ANGELES MELVIN
JOINS US FROM OUTSIDE THE
COMPLEX.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
>> GOOD EVENING.
WHAT WE KNOW IS VERY LIMITED SO
FAR BUT WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS
THAT EARLIER THIS AFTERNOON OUR
NEWSROOM GOT SOME PHONE CALLS
FROM EMPLOYEES HERE AT THIS
FACILITY TELLING US THEY WERE
BEING EVACUATED BECAUSE OF A
SUSPICIOUS PACKAGE THAT WAS
FOUND HERE THAT WAS ADDRESSED TO
MAXINE WATERS.
LET ME GIVE YOU A LIFE LOOK AT
THE SCENE RIGHT HERE.
LAPD'S BOMB SQUAD IS ON SCENE
RIGHT HERE.
WE UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE THE
ROBOT OUT AND FROM PEOPLE
WATCHING OUR SHOP DELL MY
CHOPPER I UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE
TECHNICIANS HAVE GONE INSIDE TO
TAKE X-RAYS OF THE DEVICE WHICH
IS STILL INSIDE THE BUILDING.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO SOME OF
THESE EMPLOYEES LEAVING THE
FACILITY.
SOME OF THEM ARE VERY CONFUSED
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
SOME OF THEM ARE TELLING US THEY
WEREN'T EVACUATED.
OTHERS TELLING US THEY WERE.
BUT THEY ALL KNOW THAT THIS
PACKAGE DID IN FACT HAVE MAXINE
WATERS NAME ON IT.
ONE TELLING US THAT SHE BELIEVES
THE PACKAGE HAD VERY SIMILAR
MARKINGS AND I.D. STUFF ON IT
JUST LIKE THE OTHER PACKAGES
THAT WERE FOUND THROUGHOUT THE
DAY.
THIS WOULD BE THE SECOND PACKAGE
FOUND TODAY ADDRESSED TO MAXINE
WATERS.
THIS WOULD BE, IF IT'S CONFIRMED
THAT IT SOME SORT OF EXPLOSIVE
DEVICE THIS WOULD BE I BELIEVE
THE SEVENTH BOMB.
SO RIGHT NOW LAPD'S BOMB TECHS
ON THE SCENE HERE INVESTIGATING.